in in December of 1997 I walked into a
small casting office at NBC and read the
role of will Truman for the very first
time after the first scene max Mutchnick
jumped to his feet and said just so you
know you never have to be more gay than
that which was very very moving because
it's what my father had said to me so
many times over the years my dad my dad
was an actor in the early 50s before
pursuing his his real dream of
accounting things differently in my
family but a huge piece of my DNA was
watching television comedy with him
watching mash and all in the family and
Monty Python watching him laugh until he
cried and then watching him cry when we
both realized that Colonel Henry Blake's
plane had been shot down over the Sea of
Japan
those were seminal moment seminal
moments remaining my mother Doris would
have loved this she loved Hollywood she
loved reading actors biographies I
remember so many breakfasts her coming
down and saying well I stayed up late
last night what's the late show and saw
a movie with my favorite movie star
Keith who's my favorite movie star
they were loving supportive parents and
I wish they were they were here today I
can I can just I can just hear my
father's my father's boys sing Jesus
Christ it's hot they're here in spirit
but my brother Brian my sister Ellen
might nephew Oliver are here in Bott and
I'm so grateful for that
I'm so grateful for that I've got
friends from high school here and help
Helga and Chris I've known them for 40
years I've got friends from my years in
the Canadian theatre Vince and Jen and
Murray and Vicki and so many friends
from the last 23 years in this town
thank you all for being here I got my
start in the theater the my 20s was
about the theater but when I was a kid
it was all about television I used to
take my little cassette recorder and
record the TV theme songs which would
then become theme songs from my shows
because every every game I ever played
was a TV show I couldn't I couldn't play
GI Joes without rolling the credits
first the theme Welcome Back Kotter
playing behind them but if I place the
spies or cops in the back yard
I would I would pause in the middle of
the game for a commercial break
some sometimes I would actually do the
commercial like its Cormack for right
guard I wanted to be Don Adams and Alan
Alda I wanted to kiss Barbara Feldon and
Elizabeth Montgomery and when I got a
little older and my dreams matured I
dreamed one day I would be directed by
James burrows as of last week that dream
has come true 217 times I have been so
blessed in this medium starting with my
very first Big Shell Lonesome Dove where
I got to I got to ride a horse and have
long hair and a beard and I met the love
of my life third ad Janet Holden next
year will be our 25th year together and
make make no mistake I would not be here
on this podium in front of this star
without her unwavering belief in me and
in us and in the future this is a
tribute to our journey from the moment
we met through Los Angeles till this day
this is ours
[Applause]
I've been so I've been so lucky with all
of my TV families Kent biller Ken biller
were you and my perception family for
three years I am crazy about read write
and carry mud and our cast and crew on
travellers third season premieres on
Netflix very soon die soon but I
wouldn't be here the only reason I'm
really here today is because 20 years
ago max Mutchnick and David Cohan
trusted me with the role of a lifetime
NBC trusted me and eventually a whole
community the LGBTQ community trusted me
with their story and I'm so I'm so
grateful for that for the rest of my
life with with that trust came a gift
three gifts actually Debra Messing Sean
Hayes and Meghan melodic
[Music]
[Applause]
together my friends we are we are a fist
and Shawn I know I want to make the same
joke but it's too early it's too early
it's not even noon you did the right
thing I want to thank Bob Greenblatt and
everybody at NBC for today and for
giving us a new lease on life I want to
thank all the brilliant writer producers
oval and great so we'll put these words
in my mouth for 20 years I want to thank
my my team my agents at Gersh and all
the agents for the last 20 years that
had helped me to get here okay
I want to thank Joan Tyler I want to
thank Michael and Keira and Harris and
Michelle and most especially for 23
years now I want to thank my friend and
my manager LeeAnn Cornell
these these stars are about the future
they're about generations to come
understanding and appreciating what came
before them Janet and I have only made
one significant contribution to future
generations but we think it's a pretty
goddamn good one
my son Finnegan penny this is this is
yours too
this is part of the legacy and I hope
that one day you will stand here with
your grandchildren and they'll look up
at you and say grandpa now can we go to
Universal and they will I was born in
Canada I will probably die in Canada but
a little piece of me will always be
right here where I always dreamed it
would be
thank you thank you sir Thank You chef
Anna thank you everyone at the Hollywood
Chamber of Commerce I want to thank
Michael Douglas I wanna think max
Mutchnick and I want to thank all of you
fans thank you so much it's an
incredible honor